I need either more or less speed even he
is just like okay speed speed and then
yeah and what what happened I don't know
good tricky this Bush just come here
come here magic skateboard
just come here perfect perfect
broke your feet I'm trying to karate
kick no no no no no fine no way
who sits here and is just like perfect
these controls are so intuitive
Nick let's jump up there just what great
design we do something funny bring it
home mark how can I do something funny
you know who got up here that was a
perfect setup in you you do something
funny you make it so hilariously funny
that was wrong no don't laugh yet that
wasn't what I wanted to do I know what
you want to do that's why I'm laughing
go go come on go balls first in those
well
oh that's entire time was just to make
that happen all right so thank you guys
so much for watching this has been me
and Bob Bob's shipping back to rally
very soon so there's the last game that
we're playing together I hope you guys
enjoyed it this was so much fun oh there
yeah every time every boat yeah this has
been amazingly fun so thank you all so
much for watching thanks Bob
as always see you